Because no matter
how much I hate him, or you,
what I saw in that cave, felt in my guts,
I know the demon is worse.
Terrorblade is worse.
Now please, let's fix this
before anyone else dies.
[Slyrak growling]
What is your judgment?
Let Slyrak be reborn,
and he can tell us of this demon himself.
He can share his plan.
-Wait. What?
-Destroy the body. Release the soul.
[grunting]
The human must die that Slyrak may return.
Let the Thunder sing as one voice.
[epic music]
[grunting]
Kill the little mouse. Eat it.
[groaning]
Mirana.
-[Davion] She's…
-[grunts]
He's killing her. Fucking do it!
Kill me before Slyrak kills her!
[Mirana panting, grunting]
[Mirana breathing heavily]
Come on.
I can feel you in there, Davion.
I know you have the strength.
I know you can take control.
[roars]
Davion!
Mirana.
You slay monsters, not people.
Death.
No.
[thunder rumbles]
[groans]
[grunting, groaning]
[screaming]
[roaring]
Davion…
[crash]
[exhales sharply]